con el lema matando periodistas no se
mata la verdad decenas de personas se
manifestaron frente a las instituciones
en varias ciudades mexicanas ante la
oleada de asesinatos de reporteros 5 en
lo que va de año el más reciente ever
lópez quien fue baleado en su oficina en
la ciudad de oaxaca en el suroeste del
país nos vemos enemigos del estado y
exigimos garantías para este
también exigimos que los asesinatos de
nuestros y nuestros
no queden impunes y que su labor
considerada las líneas de investigación
es justicia real
de simulación en la investigación que
supuestamente
autoridades denunciar crímenes informar
sobre corrupción o narcotráfico puede
costarle la vida a los periodistas
locales mexicanos son reporteros sin
fronteras méxico es el país más letal
para ejercer el oficio periodístico
similar a reportar desde una zona de
guerra las organizaciones como artículo
19 que documentan estas matanzas
denuncian que el 40 por ciento de estas
muertes recae en funcionarios públicos y
piden protección y el esclarecimiento de
estos casos un pedido al que se unió la
unión europea a través de un comunicado
ante el alarmante número de agresiones
contra periodistas en el país urgimos a
todas las autoridades competentes a
hacer uso de todos los medios a su
alcance para generar entornos favorables
para que las personas periodistas de
mexico puedan ejercer su profesión
libremente y sin amenazas el gobierno de
lópez obrador está siendo criticado
desde las organizaciones que denuncian
que el mandatario no ha cumplido sus
promesas de reducir la violencia y la
impunidad en el país